oh oh geez oh gosh ow oh no here i am
again guys
back in the hospital i can't believe it
man i just can't seem to stay away from
this place
oh man shattered my nose twice actually
which is
you know impressive not sad at all that
i
i broke my nose twice in the same week
but oh man it was awful
and i'm going to be here a while i'm
going to be in a full body nose cast for
quite some time i don't know when i'm
going to be getting
out of this place oh man you're probably
wondering how it happened it was
something epic incredible i got in a
fight with the chair it was really
awesome
uh but the chair got the upper hand
because it cheated came down from the
ceiling wallet me right on the snoot
and then again we were filming a newness
on this video and then all of a sudden
we were
staring down the barrel of a of a big ol
hoop coming in
right at nose height really walled me
right on the schnauz um
my nose didn't stand a chance but as you
can see well as you can see the
the hoop and the chair both been
obliterated by sheer force of impact
uh and i'm still standing so i'm
actually the better one here but oh my
god the pain
oh the pain is incredible oh man the
only reason i'm making this video is to
tell you guys how much i'm thinking
about you while i'm recovering in here
how much i wish you were here by my side
buy this hospital bed why i wish you
were here
all giving me all the booboo kisses that
i could possibly get you know actually
if you guys leave a like that is
equivalent to one bubukus
the doctor said if i can get a million
booboo kisses my nose will
maybe recover back to its original glory
but only if i get only if i get enough
booboo kisses
so i think through the power of the
internet a like is equivalent to one
bubukis
so if you guys give me a booboo kiss by
pressing the like button
we can maybe accommodate enough bubba
kisses that i can recover my nose once
and for all but i don't know if i'm
gonna make it guys
it's real it's real knife's edge here
it's real borderline it's real
cut and dry you know if i don't get
enough bubble kisses the doctor doesn't
know what my status is gonna be and who
knows
where i'm gonna be if i don't get enough
booboo kisses so you know just leave a
like for a booboo kiss
and uh you know i'll i'll be thinking
about you if you think about me and if
you think about me then hit the like
button give me one
big fat booboo kiss on my schnoot
anyway i'll be here my nose hurts